the um so you've probably seen all these
bills in uh australia and canada that
force tech companies to pay
news outlets for content this is the
american version of that it would allow
media companies to get together in a
cartel to collectively negotiate with
the tech companies on things like uh
[Music]
ads things like ads and things like
uh paying them for content and uh
so which republicans are on it well if
you're ready and paul
yes round round paul's on this lindsey
graham cynthia lomas cynthia llamas has
also signed on to really another really
terrible book
paul you you come on this show and
explain your position on this because i
trust i like rand paul so i want to hear
what he's why he's i'll i have the
answer to why so many republicans that
are on this it's because news corp is
one of the biggest pushes of this and
republicans like news corp
did you blindly trust it or something
well you know
rupert murdoch and his media companies
have them on have them on fox news
give us give us the elevator pitch of
what the bill does it says to provide a
safe harbor for publishers online of
online content to collectively negotiate
with dominant online platforms regarding
the terms on which content may be
distributed it's a it's a temporary
waiver on antitrust to basically allow
these small publishers to collectively
bargain against facebook and google
small
publishers in the building
where are the builders that say it
includes all there's a
non-discrimination provision so you like
it i like the bill i think it's a good
balance so it allows me to me my thing
is facebook and google are the bigger
enemy here and they have absolutely
destroyed local news like i want
decentralization of news i want local
newspapers to be able to report on stuff
and i think the way the model is
currently it benefits facebook and
google it's absolutely put but the the
issue is
local news has been destroyed but it's
because
people want national stories
so it used to be that to get your news
you'd turn on you know channel five for
the five o'clock news i remember we had
fox 32 in chicago yeah at simpsons we're
at like 5 30 or something and then
central time yeah central time and then
and then at 6 00 p.m was the news and
i'd go uh and then afterwards it was
seinfeld i was like meh i like the
simpsons when i was a kid and uh that
you'd watch your news but your news
would be like who's that guy on wgn is
that larry potash i don't remember he's
still there i think uh it was local
stories you'd get some national stuff
but they'd also be like a fire hydrant
burst over on the corner of 63rd and you
know california and now there's water
everywhere the road has been blocked off
and you're like
now you turn on the news at cnn and
they're like trump is a nazi and you're
like okay that's not anything relevant
to me then you go on google you type in
news you get cnn cnn's gonna give you
all national stories cbs all national
stories so you have to actively choose
as someone in an area to find your local
news but i think most people don't do
that
the other thing is you know local news
is how this is being pitched to
congressman i mean anyone who's been in
politics for a long time knows that the
great soundbite is we're on the side of
the little guys against the big guys
that's how polls have been selling
almost anything for a very very long
time
there's nothing in the bill that limits
this to local news
but there is a big part of the bill that
allows any cartel that forms to exclude
whoever they want as long as they're not
similarly situated to them i don't think
that's true so there's a lot of
scriptures and hold on bro you gotta
have a billion viewers
the bill says you can't have fewer than
one billion monthly active users in
aggregate i'd we'd have to look at the
language i think i think it's talking
about social media it's gotta be also
i'm pretty sure that draft of the jcpa
is not the most accurate the the most
recent one because there's been a lot of
work on i've i've seen uh i've actually
seen a draft of an unreleased draft of
some amendments and it's even worse
they're going to extend it by 10 years
instead of the original four that's how
long it'll apply for plus they're going
to add something that they're going to
separate into categories one for
broadcasters which they define as
stations they don't define it as
youtubers youtubers you're not going to
get a handout because of this bill tim
no no youtuber is going to get a handout
no podcaster no sub stack author is
going to get a handout it's all for the
legacy media it's all for paper
newspapers it's all for traditional
broadcasters they're trying to rescue
them from the internet
they should not be doing that no it's
it's a ballad it's the same thing
they're doing in canada it's the same
thing they're doing in uh in australia
and uh you know the way this works in dc
is that the news media alliance which is
the big umbrella lobbying group for all
the big media companies uh you should
check out their website go to go to
newsmediaalliance.org
board of directors and look at some of
the people who are who are part of this
organization that basically wrote this
bill
uh and you're not going to see a lot of
local news in there
board of directors
we've got
antoinette bush maribel wadsworth pamela
browning who are these people look at
their titles executive vice president
global head of government affairs and
news corp president of publisher usa
today
i think this courier this is very
strange because like i i just don't so
so
what would you suggest what would you
suggest as a better play to prevent
facebook and google from getting all
this ad revenue from basically like
incentivizing the nationalization of
everything it's free marketing no it
goes back to what we were saying uh when
we were talking about how evil is a big
tech
uh big tech was pressured into censoring
by advertising boycotts driven by the
media
so big tech is bad but they're bad
because they are favoring the media and
this is and this is a bill that would
force them to favor the media even more
than they are currently are doing what
we want is for them to allow everyone to
compete on an equal playing field not to
give massive handouts to the journalism
in it why why on earth would republicans
want there to be handouts to newspapers
even local newspapers which are just as
left as uh left when yeah
i don't we don't need a handout and i
don't want my competition to get free
money from the government or for
protections if these news organizations
can't figure out how to run their
business for the modern era they
shouldn't exist look i think it's a
complicated bill i think there's a lot
of arguments on both sides on it but i
will say this which is if you're going
to take on big tech the biggest problem
conservatives have is that these
companies don't respect republicans they
don't respect them as having posing any
sort of threat whatsoever to them and so
if you're not going to embrace which
olim i know we disagree on antitrust too
but if you're not going to embrace any
sort of actual solution that'll do
something to these companies they're not
going to change their you know they're
going to continue to censor i got your
solution that's free their software code
you can't break the company apart enough
times you got to make sure that the code
is available if you want democratization
of the network then everyone's got to
have sex
are we saying we have to sign on to
every tech regular
we should offer an idea we have all
these republican establishment members
i'm objecting to i'm not objecting to
all of the bills john i'm going to this
particular bill i am a huge supporter of
bill haggerty's proposed tech regulation
i'm a huge supporter of texas proposed
tech regulation well yeah we agree we
agree we agree on section two i like the
jurisdiction bill there are lots of
bills unlike this one
it's the it's the worst it's actually
i'll i will make it closer it is the
worst bill of this congress
bailing out the media the reason where
we have parents
who think it's a good idea to chemically
castrate their own children is because
the media made that idea cool the reason
why we have people supporting defunding
the police is because the media made it
into an issue the reason why we have uh
libs of tick tock being doxxed is
because of the media the reason the
entire country believed russia was in
control of the government for a full two
years is because of the media the reason
why oh yeah
children were master schools and for
republicans that support a bill that
bails out the media that's an obscene
betrayal of their voters i think that's
a really that's a really good talking
point but i don't think if you would
talk to rand paul if you would talk to
these guys i don't think that that's
i know exactly what happened the news
corp loyal the new scope lobbyists in
the news media alliance went and went
and spoke to them um
it says any print broadcast or digital
news organization that has a dedicated
professional editorial staff that
creates and distributes original news
and related content concerning local
national or international matters of
public interest on at least a weekly
basis
and is marketed through subscriptions
advertising or sponsorship provides
original news and related content with
the editorial content consisting of
consisting of not less than 25 current
news and related content blah blah blah
blah blah blah and to mine so my
knowledge there's a more recent draft
that actually even expands the larger
and
there's well the new the new one says
1500 employees but that's that's a trick
because you can always corporate
restructure your organization to make it
into little lots of little small
small 1500 employee chunks
um what you the thing you the thing you
read out there tim dedicated
professional editorial stuff that leaves
out every uh one-man independent
journalist every one-man operation on
sub second leave that glenn greenworld
glenn green will not be covered by that
we are a change leave that lucrative
glenn greenwald went before congress and
opposed this bill for the wow for uh and
you should actually watch his testimony
before the house committee it says the
bill creates a four-year safe harbor
from anti-trust laws for print broadcast
or digital news companies to
collectively negotiate with online
content distributors requiring the terms
on which the news company's content may
just be distributed by online content
content distributors i completely oppose
that in every way
you're telling me that you think the new
york times the washington post cbs abc
nbc should be able to come together
violating antitrust provisions to
negotiate collectively amongst all of
the biggest and most powerful media in
the world i don't think that's what it
does that's literally what i just read
well so as i said that's that's an older
text i know that they've excluded some
of the larger ones i my concern is local
news i want to make sure that we're not
having everything nationalized
same thing that you just mentioned
i mean it's like 117th congress 2022. no
i don't know i know there's there's okay
it hasn't been marked up there's a
there's a markup coming but the the
local news talking point is pure
marketing they know everyone dislikes
the big national media corporations
that's why they're talking about local
news they were marketing
this draft as far as who's going to be
able to deal with uh google and facebook
screwing them over more local news or
the big guys i think rather i would
rather how about this book destroy the
media machine through technological
advancement and then people like us
figure out how to pick up the pieces and
build outside of that ecosystem and
create something new through merit so
one of the things we did was over a year
ago we launched timcast.com we are
funded primarily now through memberships
we are we are we are removing our
reliance on big tech platforms and we
have been reducing our reliance on big
tech platforms the next thing we're
going to be doing is doing mobile apps
and tv smart tv apps we are finding a
way to navigate this we've got
infrastructure being built right now to
make us more sensor resilient and i do
not want to see cnn team up with the
washington post in the new york times to
give themselves more power by leveraging
the weight of their massive
conglomeration
against facebook and google leaving all
of us holding an empty bank and you know
i was covering this from the beginning
this favoring of the media it's the
culmination of that trend so facebook
already pays billions to news companies
in licensing google has port bill
hundreds of millions if not billions
into propping up the media already and
they're doing that because they've been
told for five years by the by the media
if you don't favor us we're going to
whip up advertiser boycotts and this is
a part of that is trying to enshrine
that same trend in law the worst trend
of silicon valley promoting the media
and making what was previously an even
playing field uneven
by the way i also want to bring up one
one uh tremendous uh tremendous little
statistic i found recently
according to gallup
as of 2021
11
of republicans have a great deal or a
fair amount of trust in the media 11
percent
and according to pew
the number of republicans who think
abortion should be legal
in all or most cases is 35
so the media
are less popular with republicans than
abortion
wow thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you